la desinformación que hubo sobre el tema
de la extradición tuvo un impacto
significativo en los resultados de esta
consulta popular
en buenos un saludo a todos sí hubo una
una desinformación bastante grande en el
país además que la campaña tanto para
los gobiernos seccionales es decir el
gobierno local como la la consulta
popular el referéndum constitucional fue
muy escasa es decir dura mucho muy poco
tiempo la gente no tuvo tiempo de
digerir de analizar todas las preguntas
y los anexos a las preguntas y bueno el
contexto ha determinado o o está
determinando una tendencia hacia el no
para el referéndum constitucional y
hacia una respuesta positiva para para
la revolución ciudadana ahora lo que
vemos hasta ahora es que el no sigue
consolidándose en el plebiscito de
Guillermo lasso se ve el gobierno
afectado de alguna manera por este
resultado sin duda alguna el referéndum
constitucional buscaba reformas
constitucionales para en palabras del
gobierno luchar contra el narcotráfico
la delincuencia organizada pero sin duda
alguna se convirtió en un plebiscito A
favor o en contra del gobierno de manera
que el no se tiene que leer o se lee
como también una una respuesta adversa
de la ciudadanía a la gestión de
gobierno un golpe duro para un Gobierno
ya debilitado y que nos dice por ejemplo
las victorias del correísmo en estas
elecciones
eso también resulta o llama la atención
porque el correísmo obtiene no solamente
resultados positivos en dos de las
ciudades más grandes del país sino en
las cuatro ciudades más importantes del
país y eso eh cambia un poco el
escenario político un escenario político
en el que el correísmo parecía ir un
poco hacia atrás de alguna forma estas
estas elecciones lo que hace es
demostrar que al contrario que la
revolución ciudadana tiene muchísimo
todavía por dar al país No ahora que
decir sobre las demoras en la entrega de
los resultados y una falta de
pronunciamiento por parte del Consejo
Nacional electoral
bueno el conteo siempre demora de hecho
el tiempo para contar en los votos en
efecto es una votación muy grande
nosotros tuvimos ocho papeletas la
ciudadanía tuvo ocho papeletas que para
para sufragar tanto en lo que refiere a
gobiernos locales como la consulta
popular el conteo no es un conteo
sencillo es un conteo que puede durar
para tener los resultados oficiales
hasta ocho días sin embargo ya en este
momento llevan más del 50% de las actas
escrutadas